Find a bigger stage.
A challenge for a lot of entrepreneurs
is the product or service that you’re selling
isn’t really all that great or different.
It’s just average, it’s boring
and it’s one of the main reasons why
80% of companies will fail.
80% of new businesses will fail in the first 5 years
because your stuff is boring,
it’s just okay,
it’s average.
What you need to do first is find something that’s great
something that you can excel at
and be one of the best in the world at
and when you find that
and for those of you entrepreneurs who are on that path
who are doing something important
who poured your passion into this business that you’re creating
and you’re not just creating average, okay
get by products and services
what you’re doing is going to change the world;
when you get to that point then you need to find a bigger stage.
You need to let the world know
about what you’re doing
and how good you are.
One of my favorite stories is of Eminem.
And when he was first getting started
he had a tough upbringing, he came from a broken home
his parents weren’t together
he lived with various members of his family
bounced around from state to state.
He pursued rap because he loved doing it
but he couldn’t make any money off of it.
He took jobs at restaurants
to just make ends meet.
But he thought to himself, ‘You know what – I’m really good.
I want to make a business out of this.
I want to become a professional rapper.
Even though at the time there were no white rappers, right.
People looked at him and laughed.
“You’re white. You’re rapping? What are you, crazy?”
And he felt he was good enough
that he needed to find a bigger stage.
And his bigger stage moment came
in 1997 at the Rap Olympics in Los Angeles.
When he went there he was dead broke.
He had nothing. He had no money.
He was evicted from his house the day before and that night
he had to break into his house
sleep on the floor just so he had a place to sleep
before going to LA for the Rap Olympics.
Everything was on the line for him
and he went to the Rap Olympics in LA
and he won second place.
And that was all he needed.
That was the turning point.
He went from poorly bankrupt broke, everybody laughed at him
to now being
noticed.
And Dr. Dre who was a producer
looked at him, listened to his tapes and said
“I want to sign this guy.
” People said“Dre, you’re crazy. Dude’s white.”
He said, “I don’t care if he’s purple.
If he can rap I want to be working with him.”
And that was the start of Eminem’s career.
He put all this work, effort, passion
love into making his rap something meaningful
but it only really took off
when he found his bigger stage at the Rap Olympics.
So if you’re really good at what you do
if you love doing it, if you’re creating something special
you’re not just selling an average product or service
there’s something unique about what you’re doing
and it’s really making an impact on people’s lives
then you need to find your bigger stage moment.
And it may be scary
it may mean jumping out of your comfort zone
it may mean doing things that you haven’t done before
but if you want to have a real impact
if you want to really build a significant business
if you want to look back on your life and say
“Yeah, I did that.
I’m proud of the mark that I left on this world”
then you need to embrace the fear
go with it anyway
and find your bigger stage opportunity.
Believe.
For those of you watching, you like the video
you can support me by clicking on the link below in the description.
Leave a comment. Let me know what you think
and click on my face to subscribe to the channel.
Thank you so much, I’ll see you soon.